les prix du pétrole a presque doublé de
valeur depuis l'automne dernier avec une
accélération depuis le début de l'année
le wti américain est passé de 48 dollars
le baril à la fin du mois de décembre à
64 dollars ce soir à près de 68 dollars
même il y a quelques jours avec nous
pour en parler ce soir mathieu d'anjou
économiste chez desjardins bonsoir
bonsoir
alors comment vous l'expliquez vous la
remontée des cours du pétrole
en ce moment je pense que la dernière
partie de 40 quelques dollars 65 dans la
france est vraiment lié à l'amélioration
claire des perspectives économiques
qu'on a avec la vaccination s'accélère
avec la chute des cols la deuxième vague
finalement corse et plus vite que les
gens pensaient et vous voyez vous
parliez de le céder à tantôt c'est la
même chose dans notre côté tout le monde
est en train de revoir fortement à la
hausse ses prévisions croissance entre
autres à cause des plans de soutien aux
états unis qui vont beaucoup soutenir la
demande donc un optimiste sur la
croissance et ça se traduit par une
hausse assez généralisé le des prix des
matières premières industrielles donc le
bois est très en demande est très cher
les métaux de base sont très très cher
aussi et on voit un peu la même chose du
côté du pétrole et au même temps l'offre
de pétrole a été réduite au cours de la
dernière année par les pays producteurs
par le peuple notamment donc l'offre est
réduite à un moment où on s'attend à ce
que la demande augmente
oui ça c'était un point très important
le pétrole fait bien de la mener parce
que la demande de pétrole c'est moins
spectaculaire
les autres matières premières pourraient
pas encore complètement partie donc on a
des perspectives intéressantes mais ça
sera pour une demande si forte que ça
mais l'offre a été assez contraint par
le ppc ses partenaires et aussi de côte
est américaine qu'on a une très forte
baisse pendant la pandémie et il allait
production américaine tardent à remonter
donc du pétrole qui ont été retirés et
ce congrès fut surpris la semence et
même l'arabie saoudite pourrait décider
de ramener du pétrole maintenant que les
prix sont à des niveaux intéressants et
préfère attend donc une prudence la
porte des producteurs de pétrole va
regarder un marché assez serré pour
contre 8 faire redescendre les histoires
que le sont quand même relativement
élevé les stocks de pétrole
est ce que c'est cette remontée des prix
du
et qui explique qu'ils expliquent
essentiellement la remontée des prix de
l'essence dont les gens que les gens
constatent présentement
oui c'est vraiment leur facteur dominant
qu'on a des grosses variations comme ça
des prix du pétrole comme on a connu
depuis un an
c'est vraiment seul qui a un impact
direct sur les prix de l'essence sur ce
quoi ce sera quoi la répercussion du
prix de l'essence sur l'économie parce
que l'on me rende un dollar prend ton
dollars 35
à quoi faut-il s'attendre sur l'économie
sion d'inflation l'effet le plus
spectaculaire est à mettre sur le taux
d'inflation
donc le taux d'inflation annuel c'est
toujours qu'on parlait d'une année à
l'autre et dans les prochains mois se
comparer avec une période clé le prix du
pétrole est en bois de 20 dollars le
baril le prix de l'essence était autour
des 90 où le litre donc le convoi
comparer avec nos prix de l'essence à
une veine 30
ça va avoir un gros effet sur
l'inflation donc temporairement on
s'attend à ce que l'inflation canadienne
remonte au-dessus des 3% il pourrait
même s'approcher des 4 % voire le
dépasser en avril
normal son spectaculaire pour l'indicé
général 3 4%
quand même c'est quand même beaucoup oui
c'est beaucoup la seule chose c'est que
tout le monde est conscient que c'est
des effets temporaires qui viennent
beaucoup de la comparaison avec les prix
très faibles de la passe donc à l'avant
du canada panique repos la cause de
cette hausse de l'inflation mais tim
qu'on est déjà dans un mode du conte
parle de risque de surchauffe sur
stimulation de l'économie basque pas ce
qui va aider à calmer les choses
faro surtout sur maïs comme on pense la
pression l'inflation va retourner assez
rapidement la cid de bourse à un prix du
pétrole élevés fait généralement
contribuent généralement la hausse du
dollar canadien qui s'en va selon vous
est-ce que vous croyez au delà des 81
cents américains
oui on pense qu'il ya un mois qui les a
flanché à ce niveau là mais à notre avis
devrait rester près des 80 franchir les
gens demandent une somme de fin d'année
à 80 sous ios donc un peu comme les prix
des matières premières on pense quand
même le gros de la hausse effet on voit
pas le plus du pétrole conflit remonter
beaucoup en france mais cet été un peu
trop rapide pour les prix du pétrole
dans un contexte sous cloche risque de
réagir tant du côté de l'arabie saoudite
qui est des états unis mais
la devise canadienne devrait être
capable de passer au dessus des 80 sous
légèrement mais recule à tuchan est
intéressant de surveiller un peu les
messages des banques centrales
ceci la prochaine chose à sauver il avec
les perspectives économiques sont
meilleures comment la banque du canada
comment la fed vont réagir et ce après
avoir un impact important sur les
devises le michigan menace de fermer le
robinet de la ligne 5 du pipeline trans
frontaliers den bridge qui vient après
approvisionner les raffineries de l'est
du canada
pourquoi mais je pense c'est certain que
les oléoducs composent sont pas très
populaires dans ce moment particulier
qu'un traverse les frontières on a vu
l'administration brydon que rejeter
keystone xl ça semble être un peu dans
la même mouvance mais c'est quand même
assez différent puisque ça pas être
langue qu'il est depuis 1953 qui était
déjà en rénovation mais c'est surtout
pour des préoccupations
environnementales
si on ferme le robinet ce qu'un effet
sur notre prix de l'essence ici oui je
pense qu'il faudrait s'attendre que ça
créerait un peu de problèmes
d'approvisionnement temporairement et
donc il risquait d'avoir des hausses
supplémentaires des prix de l'essence
québec ontario peut-être les hausses des
prix du propane du côté des messieurs
puisqu'il se fait mal aussi dans le
nord-est des etats-unis est tout aussi
approvisionnée par cette ligne et il y
aurait aussi de côté du pétrole de
l'alberta
ça pourrait créer créer un problème
panama fédéral a accepté la décision sur
kiss ton mais sans vraiment vouloir
mettre la pression pour laver avec cette
nouvelle hausse qui on va surveiller sur
mathieu d'anjou remercie pour ses
explications ce soir très plaisir pour
voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit